[Music]
in why pero por que it's more like a
yeah Mele federal why why that mean like
why put her a girl
no mine Ches submitted by drunken horse
oh my god my favorite fight stance ever
actually I don't know what a drunken
horse is what's the fight sounds like I
think he made it up I made it up
racist a heartbroken man purposely
crashed his car into a Porsche
dealership oh [ __ ] but because the other
dude that the girl was into trouble
Porsche oh that's a good one a really
good theory I wouldn't even think of
that
I would have been like what's the
cheapest dealership sign up to pay that
much but I still want to do it are you
dead
oh wait he didn't die no oh well where
did I get that he's heartbroken I don't
know he's heartbroken yeah what the [ __ ]
do better white but all right take me to
the closest English [ __ ] kid Porsche
this happened in time why is i learning
all my favourite cars they're so little
so there's Evan in Toronto this 20 year
old man wears it all so valid name Oh
rock Mutulu Oh Dax Tanner sighs [ __ ]
module oh so good living Dan therefore
the G yeah just conquer B so happened it
could be the khabib nurmagomedov so he
he's 20 years old right so he drives a
Yaris the Toyota yard
okay and well [ __ ] car yeah no wonder
he didn't die he was going like 20 miles
per hour speed ya are such [ __ ] [ __ ]
dude they go we can't go uphill when you
have at least like three people in that
phone hey you drivin a lemon you can't
say that my car goes uphill and elements
are go it doesn't have a Cadillac
convertible a catalytic converter Dan'l
it it it got stolen because I lived next
to Highland Park everybody wants me not
to have this car even God giving me so
yeah he goes my styled stop being an
idiot
and I'm like no girl I never said [ __ ]
no no that's the homie right dear
well I don't know you having him on your
back on York in your corner is a good
thing I believe it is dude we're doing
great things
second adidas pretty much yes oh yes so
this dude he ended up driving his car
into a Porsche dealership Porsche in
Toronto and once though once he crashed
through he crashed through with the yard
somehow that yards would have dismantled
and hit a wall hitting glass and then
crashing and a glass of the whole car
just breaks around he's still there he
went through the window he's in the
chair
no that's not the same okay okay he hit
it and then the car split in half he's
just there like this pristine yeah her
job was that he flew through and started
skidding that's true cuz I saw Mario
Kart scenario ngo's joke she he breaks
through the window but he's still in the
car and he's just like spinning around
and he's
no but everything fell I didn't check I
just picture this - and then the whole
shell splits in half [ __ ] you well I
show you photos oh he didn't even hit
any car he destroyed two of them no it
was actually closer but they took this
photo when they pulled it out of oh yeah
they destroy it or just like the back
panel needs to be replaced
yeah yeah but they can't sell it at full
pricing like eighty thousand yeah I want
him especially if it's like a
collector's car it's like [ __ ] it's
damaged [ __ ]
and then okey so he crashed through
right then he started like revving up
the car and he created this like big-ass
smoke he filled out it yeah inside and
then he got out and he got a permanent
marker and started writing on the other
cars that didn't get damaged this is
like a terrorist act he wrote something
like I'll show you and then another car
you wrote Eve so they're saying and then
someone that imagine it's the rapper Eve
that is in love with where'd she go
right the is there some relation to the
specific dealership like the guy the
thing like there isn't and he was so
there were people that worked at that
dealership and they were like dude why
are you doing this and he ended up
saying I'm having a bad day like that
makes it okay to do that
like okay alright keep going bro yeah
you know where this dealership was
positioned it was right across the
street from a police station oh so did
the cops just run across you just ran
across cuz people working at the front
desk heard the whole commotion and then
he they just ran across the street and
arrested him and police are saying that
they suspect that like he was just so
heartbroken or whatever and like so just
out of it that he wanted to be
incarcerated
I keep did this on purpose o for
attention if you really loved me you
would bail me out what was the message
you're not gonna get away with I'll show
you
oh I'll show you yeah what the [ __ ]
she's she's like at home reading the
news like okay yeah it's crazy because
she just made it easier to never have to
run into exactly yeah so now she's like
extra free what did she say to him I bet
you're not gonna run your yards into a
[ __ ] specific oh you don't think they
care you're not a man yeah you're not
gonna run your car into a Porsche do it
right all over 200 yeah the one for the
police station I'll show you let me
prove it to you so all that damage which
was mostly like the amount here was
because of the course it was 75202 US
dollars it was a hundred thousand
Canadian dollars that's not too bad yeah
super the night I mean that's a [ __ ] ton
of money my thought I was gonna be in
the millions yeah I thought it was gonna
be because then the building you have to
pay for the building but it wasn't like
a color like it was a Panamera it looked
like it was like a 20-man or not this is
like a hundred grand or something well
there's two cars and then but the
permanent marker is really easy to get
off because there's a wax on top so you
just use get rid of the wax layer and
then you really you could just do fine
oh that's crazy someone's so heartbroken
that they do crazy things man I mean
that's as crazy as a school shooter to
me like someone who who gets mad and he
just comes in and starts shooting I mean
thank goodness that this guy had a yard
yeah and that no one was standing there
like looking at the back porch that he
happened to the [ __ ] right to a
[ __ ] Corolla have been on a Camry
Sienna over dude
keep moving up maybe she was just
talking [ __ ] about his Yaris he's like
yours can't go through that [ __ ]
window
I'll show you oh you Eve Oh interesting
I'm looking for a new car though I need
a new car you are well because my Tesla
ends up in June I'm not what have you
been looking at well I want to get a
hybrid car buy one a hybrid but then the
hybrid SUVs the options aren't that
great so the only one that I found out
that I liked was the Acura MDX because
you can get captain chairs in the back
and they do have a hybrid version
captain turn so it's like front seats in
the back yeah it's like for front seat
DSO so long so it's really cool right
problem with that [ __ ] is is that Acura
so [ __ ] stupid because they only sell
their specific car models like in
specific type of packages that you can't
switch out of stuff so I can't if I get
this rim it has to be this type of car
so so [ __ ] and then it's all the
interest is would I hate that would
claim I should have to market oh I mean
I can't get captain chairs so the
Catholic Church are stuck with their one
or and then if I want the hybrid car I
can't switch out the wheels I can't get
captain chairs and it's wood on the
inside I call it the geezer package yeah
it just looked like some 50 or 60 year
old man is gonna buy this [ __ ] but then
you like other things but everything
else has to have the geezer package on
it the specific demographic that they
want to purchase their car in that I
like the wood [ __ ] and I'm not that old
bro I'm gonna look dope in a ring yeah
it was too expensive and they don't have
hybrids always looking for higher I want
hybrids because I already don't like
putting gas in my car cause it's kind of
annoying so I need that [ __ ] to last a
little longer
and I need I don't want a SUV like I'm
too tight for those small cars now all
the X is are there any hybrid trucks huh
no but Jeep is coming out with the truck
though oh yeah they are the Model X is
cool but I don't had the Model S so it's
like it feels like I'm buying the same
car and I want that new experience again
oh go thick because the interior is
essentially the same so it's like yeah
so I'm waiting for that BW to come out
with that electric micro bus when is
that coming out 2020 that was a joke
no it's not yeah so they project to come
out in 2020 all the jokes that come out
of his mouth are his actual wants yeah
I do want that [ __ ] dude but they don't
come out with great hybrids they try to
kill the earth dude but not us here yeah
yeah I joined the team they need to come
out with those half land half water
vehicles that the military has so we can
[ __ ] go go on a boat go to kibbutz I
forgot it's like yeah it's like a
amphibious mission like yeah yeah it's
[ __ ] dope you call it that yeah you
could go out and go to go to the ocean
whatever what is it that one it's like a
big balloon at the bottom I don't want
to pay over 50 grand for a car anymore
like that's just my max I just don't
care about cars enough good for me to
spend anything more than that now cuz I
realized that when I get a new car the
novelty dies out fast and it doesn't
make me happy so that's like from here
on out 2019 with - we'll never I gotta
invest in things that make me happy and
if cars don't make me happy why invest
into it Oh Murray condorman method spark
joy pakka joy give me the element the
element I'm going to get rid of because
it keeps getting jacked enjoy I think
everybody hates that car so much they
just destroy it for fun yeah so I don't
know what's going oh so by the way well
now I feel bad for the element like it's
getting bullied that's what I'm saying
dude
I spy behind it Simon it reminds me of a
child Ella me dude I have a lot of
utility but I'm a big guy I will tell
you this yo you know what happened oh
and this is kind of my fault so you know
I was like 2019 is a [ __ ] fresh new
year things are gonna be dope
so with this element alone [ __ ] me over
this is these are the three things that
happen so I'm like okay the air
conditioner broke whatever I gotta go
get that fixed
whatever it's still cold you don't need
it right now yeah and so I needed to go
get it fixed because there was something
wrong with it so I go in and oh I had to
get a smile check for I go get a smile
check they're like well there's
something wrong with your car because
your thermostat thing is [ __ ] up and I
was like okay what the [ __ ] be sure to
replace it I go back the person that
worked there lied that they didn't
replace it and they say were skimming
off the top of the place so I had my old
part in there but they charged me for a
new
I'm already pissed they hooked me up
whatever they fix that issue right I go
back I parked this car some lady [ __ ]
hits the back of my car so there's like
a little dent in the back now so I got
rear-ended that same day already pissed
off then that night my [ __ ] uh my
[ __ ] Cadillac catalytic converter
three [ __ ] things in a matter of two
days yeah I'm done with the car because
the car doesn't like it was bad luck
yeah yeah is this bad luck it's like I
know if I fixed it it'll be fine and the
car runs great it's worth whatever that
it is but now I have bad feelings for it
it's not bad look that's just what
happens when you buy a older car people
just jack it and they [ __ ] it up yeah I
mean I mean and all the things that are
messed up to it that's just normal wear
and tear how did that guy have to lie
yeah but the lying guy saying that you
replaced something and they charge for
that car and then the lady heating your
car that's one you gotta build a
relationship with the mechanic I've
always had used cars yeah so it's like I
don't trust nobody man I just said that
the catalytic converter getting stolen
got was the last straw but I'm like I'm
done because I had to fix up this car
just to get it running in the first
place that thing happening was like I'm
done with this car now because now it's
just stressing me out and it was
supposed to be my joy car
[Music]